un cúmulo de escombros y calles
desiertas en el centro de nashville
capital del estado sureño de tennessee
eeuu durante la mañana de navidad una
gran explosión sacudió el corazón del
ocio de la ciudad minutos antes del
estallido de una autocaravana bomba el
vehículo comenzó a transmitir un
escalofriante mensaje pregrabado
alertando de la detonación la policía
habla de un acto intencional que deja
tres heridos leves esta mañana alrededor
de las cinco y treinta los oficiales
respondieron a una llamada por disparos
en el centro de la ciudad de red
mientras los oficiales respondían se
encontraron con una autocaravana que
tenía una grabación diciendo que una
potencial bomba detonaría en 15 minutos
generales luego de la advertencia los
agentes se apresuraron a evacuar a los
vecinos de la zona pero la explosión
causó daños estructurales en varios
edificios y la onda expansiva derribó
también árboles y rompió ventanas a
cientos de metros
un oficial también resultó levemente
herido el fbi está dirigiendo la
investigación como un posible acto de
terrorismo y la policía local está
realizando interrogatorios
no sabemos si había alguien dentro de la
caravana cuando explotó así que no puedo
decirles en este momento si existe la
posibilidad de una fatalidad en ese
escenario en acción era la
administración federal de aviación
suspendió temporalmente todos los vuelos
desde nashville debido a los fallos en
las telecomunicaciones asociadas a la
explosión mientras la cruz roja local
está brindando refugio a los vecinos
desalojados